if you ever visit the vsauce office the
first thing you'll notice is that the
curiosity box has pretty much taken over
every surface of the building it looks
like a brain food machine took a massive
dump in here
and i love it it tickles me pink that i
get to make educational things that
people wind up holding
in their own hands you can't do that
with a video
now i want to give you a sneak peek this
is a puzzle that will be in a future box
i don't want to give too much away for
those of you who like the mystery but i
will show
one piece these pieces could have been
any color but i wanted the color of each
piece
to spark an entire conversation so this
isn't just light blue it is uranian blue
the average color of the planet uranus
now to be fair
not everything in this office is
whimsically joyous for example
you want a bag of asbestos we got one of
those
but the best thing about this office is
that no matter where you go
you can't get away from me